it's time to debug the ultimate myth is
there a heaven for TV shows everyone's
favorite walrus and ginger duo will be
no more after Mythbusters finishes its
13-year run ending with season 14 next
year we can only assume that Adam will
be taking up other jobs and Jamie will
be returning to the sea where he belongs
we'll miss you guys the Discovery
Channel's long-running science
experiment show MythBusters is coming to
an end entertainment weekly reports the
show will end after 2016's 14th and
final season during the shows run stars
Jamie Hyneman and Adam Savage and their
team conducted 2950 experiments in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly the
star said they've known about the show's
forthcoming cancellation for a year now
they've used that time to prepare an
epic send-off for the final episode of
Mythbusters it was my greatest fear that
Mythbusters would just stop and we
wouldn't be able to do proper final
episode savage said so whether it's
myths about human behavior or car
stories or explosion stories we try to
find the most awesome example of each
category and filled on our past history
so what was your favorite Mythbusters
experiment what would you like to see
them debunk before they leave us forever
let us know in the comments below or
come find me on Twitter at how not to
draw i'm kate and thanks for watching